hey guys it's max for max sec today
we're gonna be comparing Microsoft's new
surface pro X which is their iPad pro
killer against a 12 point 9 inch iPad
pro we're going to look at variety of
different things such as the exterior
design and the build quality the
displays the keyboards the Pens the
performance speakers and more let's jump
right into it and start off with design
so looking at the backs of them here I
really like how the surface pro X looks
it's very clean we just have the Windows
logo or the surface Microsoft logo here
and if we grab them into our hands the
iPad has this really square iPhone 5
style design and it's very symmetrical
all around the bezels are symmetrical
square all around and it feels really
nice and premium now the surface pro X
does have this a little curve so it's
not squared off and then we have the
button sticking out more so we have the
little stand that pops out little
indents here so it doesn't seem as
premium we have some holes in the bottom
for the case but in general it is a
little bit more comfortable in the hand
because it isn't square it has a subtle
curve on the back taking a look at the
front we have very slim bezels on the
sides even though we have built-in
speakers on either side the chin and the
forehead are a much thicker and we do
have sensors built in here for face
authentication up here at the top
everything is nice and smooth when we
transition between the glass and the
frame and then coming to this edge we
start feeling a little bit of sharp
edges here where the glass is sunk
deeper and it is really extreme here
almost like an get scratched because the
glass isn't sitting flush now the iPad
has quad speakers we have two on each
side and it does work in stereo mode but
if we look at the bottom we just have a
one USB type-c ports whereas the surface
pro X not only does it have two USB
type-c ports right over here they also
have a special Microsoft connection here
and the included charger in the box is a
high power charger that will connect in
here and it's magnetically detachable so
it can't get yanked and also charged
from zero to hundred percent in about an
hour and a half compared to the 18 watt
charger with the iPad it takes about
three and a half hours now it is rated
at 13 hours of battery life but because
of the screen reflectivity and having a
habit in full performance mode pretty
much all the time and it actually runs
about 6 hours of battery life in real
world use compared to the iPad which is
rated at 10 hours of battery life and
that's about what it actually gets now
the last major difference on the outside
of the devices is the fact that the
surface pro X has a built-in stand so
you can pop it up like this it is very
stiff so you have a really big range of
adjustability if you want to use it like
this with a built-in keyboard you can or
if you're watching movies you can prop
it up like this whereas the iPad does
not have that does have a square edge if
I don't wanna be balancing it like this
so for that you will be needing the
keyboard covers now both of these have
their own covers the iPad is a little
bit more expensive and we'll be talking
about prices towards the end of this
video but it does offer some protection
for the back of the device it is
magnetic so it just Alliance by itself
clips in and we have two ranges of
adjustability here for you to use it
personally I really like the surface the
fact that you have all the levels of
adjustability whether you're using it on
your lap or using at a desk you can
adjust it to the perfect angle which is
much more convenient now it also has a
hidden feature in here and that is the
pen holder so here is the pen for the
device and you just drop it in and if
it's the wrong direction it will
actually flip and start charging and if
you don't need it you can actually pop
up the keyboard like this and hide it
which is very nice now the iPad just
attaches the pen magnetically to the top
like that that means if you throw it
into your bag it can get bumped off and
mean it's fairly secure but it can get
detached where this one is nice hidden
stored and you're not gonna lose it even
though the surface access keyboard is
less expensive it packs in a lot more
features if we just look at them the
first thing you'll notice is that we
have a trackpad now the trackpad won't
set any records it's not amazing but it
will get the job done and it's better
than not having it at all and not having
Mouse support really it feels decent you
can
with it you can do different gestures
and along with that we also have a
variety of other features we have
shortcut keys here we can adjust the
brightness we can actually turn on
backlighting which the keyboard has
built-in media keys stuff like that
whereas the iPads keyboard doesn't have
a trackpad you can adjust the screen
very much with it and you're missing
those shortcuts meaning you're gonna be
reaching for the touchscreen much more
often now the actual keyboards
themselves once again it is better on
the surface cover we have a surprising
amount of key travel here and while it's
not gonna set any records once again for
a little attachment cover it is quite
good whereas the iPads has less key
travel and it just doesn't feel as nice
it feels quite shallow and everything is
covered with this little material on
here
now you can get used to it and tied
fairly well with it but if I have to
compare both these the surfaces actual
keyboard cover is miles ahead now let's
compare the displays the surface uses a
3 by 2 aspect ratio whereas the iPad
uses 4 by 3 meaning it has a little bit
more vertical resolution which is nice
for webpages but it is a downside if you
watch videos because your black bars are
going to be larger now as far as the
actual resolution the pixels per inch is
very similar both them are gonna have
really nice details nice and sharp icons
tech stuff like that because they're so
similar and as far as the color accuracy
the surface has 99% srgb meaning it's
fairly color accurate but the iPad goes
a step above that and has about 25% more
colors with the DCI p3 rating now as far
as brightness they are fairly similar
the iPad is rated for 500 nits compared
to 450 but there is one massive
difference between the two and that is
screen reflectivity Apple has top line
coatings so it blocks out so much of the
reflections and that means you can use
it at lower brightness levels without
seeing other stuff and having
distractions whereas the surface the
reflectivity is very poor you see
everything so you kind of have to max
out the brightness and even still you
see quite a bit of reflections
especially if you're in brighter rooms
or using outside which is a major bummer
another downside of the iPad
is because of iOS you can only play back
at 1080p quality whereas with Windows
the service Pro X can actually support
8k video at 60 frames per second now the
processor is too slow but you can handle
4k 60 frames per second but a downside
of the surface is on the contrast is
much lower compared to the iPad which
has truer blacks now one of the biggest
differences between the displays is the
fact that the surface pro X runs at a
standard 60 frames per second whereas
the iPad pro has Pro motion meaning it
can run at up to 120 frames per second
but not only that it can actually scale
down to 60 30 or even 24 frames per
second depending on what you're doing
that way it saves battery life as well
and that can be seen if we're on the
home screen say we're flipping through
different apps or if you have some kind
of anything open like say a web browser
everything is extremely fluid I mean you
can't really even show this offer and
know what it feels like unless you've
actually used it compared to your
standard 60 Hertz which when you compare
them side-by-side it looks a lot more
choppy and kind of blurry when you're
scrolling through things now another way
that promotion really helps is when you
are using a pen the drawing experience
is fantastic on the high pad Pro Apple
not only has a 120 Hertz screen they
also have been refining the delay and
minimizing it so when we look at this
side-by-side in slow motion you could
definitely tell that the iPad is more
responsive there's almost no lag now
with the surface pro X you do have a
little bit delay but it is not bad for
more normal drawing and the pressure
sensitivity is really quite good now
where we start to have an issue is if we
have different effects say like this
glitter pen here or for stacking
different layers you start getting
really bad delay and it becomes really
difficult to use all right guys now it's
time to compare the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
if you're somebody that wants to use
your device to have web conferences use
FaceTime with the iPad this is the
quality of the video in the audio that
you can expect from the iPad pro and
this is the quality with the Microsoft
Surface book s so go ahead let me know
down in the comment section below which
one looks better and which one sounds
better now for something that you guys
have been waiting for and that is
performance now the iPad pro has a crazy
a 12x Bionic processor with super high
performance and here we have Microsoft's
custom Snapdragon sq1 I have Geekbench 5
open I'm gonna run these but I do want
to mention that the graphics doesn't
even show up and he can't try so we
won't be able to test that with this
program but we can't test the CPU scores
so let's go ahead and get that going the
iPad pro has 4 gigs of RAM at least in
most of the models whereas the surface
pro X has 8 gigs ram as base you can go
all the way up to 16 gigs now you may
think that that's gonna help performance
with the surface pro X but not really
because it's running full windows and
needs a lot more system resources
compared to I pad OS which is very well
optimized for that amount of RAM and as
far as actual real-world performance
well you guys will see that in just a
second so the results are in and the
iPad pro is more than 50 percent faster
in single core and more than 60 percent
faster in multi-core and that is a
substantial difference but that doesn't
mean that the score of the surface pro X
is bad by any means it is pretty
respectable but that is only in this
benchmark now the difference does show
up when we're actually using them and
doing various things now I have some
hands-on time with the surface pro X and
so far I've been fairly disappointed
for example as we've been shooting this
video we've been browsing the web
playing back these YouTube videos and
the iPad is super smooth performs great
whereas the surface pro X is quite laggy
so let's go ahead and open this up and
let's maximize this video here there you
go I actually touched it first on the
surface pro X and then the iPad and you
guys see what is happening right there
and then if we open up our power mode we
are set to the best performance and
that's when I was talking about having
to be set to the best performance and
the battery life starts going
not so good and then things like
scrolling in the timeline here I'm gonna
grab this scrolling is super smooth
we're getting the preview for the
thumbnail you guys see all of that lag
right there and this is in a higher
performance mode let's do a web browser
test I'm gonna open up YouTube at the
same time on both of them so that was
really fast
let's hit search here for a Mac sec
alright that popped up we have the same
video right over here and do keep in
mind that this is not in the app this is
in the web browser Safari versus edge
both they come pre-loaded with open that
up this is loading and going scrolling
down here and let's switch to another
video pretty much instant here here
hasn't even done anything yet there you
go and we are loading up I have
speedometer web browser test right here
so let's go ahead and run that the
results are in and the iPad pro scored
132 compared to thirty eight point nine
nine so basically 39 there and so that
just shows you the performance
difference when you're in the web
browser and that is using Safari and
edge which should be optimized now the
reason why we have such a big difference
in performance and why we're getting
glitchyness even when it sets a high
performance mode is because windows is
not really designed for this ARM
processor the processor in here the
reason I put it in is because it can
make the device lightweights not heat up
be power efficient but we're having a
lot of issues a software wise now a lot
of programs can't even be run for
example I couldn't download Premiere Pro
to test video editing it's not even
supported same thing with Lightroom the
mobile version and Lightroom classic now
I was able to get Photoshop in here and
we all go ahead and open it up and the
performance is really poor here I'm
importing a file and as you guys can see
I'm pulling this lighter everything is
crazy choppy and this is actually
running worse than a tooth
fifteen a base-model MacBook Pro with
four gigs of RAM that is quite a bit
smoother and everything just really
stalls I get errors that show up right
here saying is we don't have enough
video RAM and it really makes it
unusable so a lot of really powerful
apps are you're used to using that I
designed for windows will not even work
because they're designed in 64-bit and
there's not that many 32-bit apps and a
lot of ones that are available like this
one are outdated and they are quite slow
so here you guys see me zooming in you
guys can see all that stutter and that's
without any layers that's just one layer
right there and this is the issue that
the surface pro X is going to have the
iPad does not have a full operating
system it has iPad a wesen here but
Apple has been updating it over the
years we've had a big improvement with
the latest release we have files app
support for external drives and the
ecosystem with the crazy amount of
optimized apps is really nice so we
don't have full Mac OS but the apps that
we do have such as Lightroom here I'll
go and open up that same photograph and
you guys can see the difference in
performance here I'm dragging the slider
everything is absolutely instant no lag
it can zoom in look at that I mean the
performance for photo editing is really
really good top line you can do pro work
with this tablet now with that said
which one would I rather buy and for me
it is a no-brainer even if you are not
in the Apple ecosystem at all the iPad
pro makes a lot of sense especially you
start using it everything is super fluid
from the web browser to all the apps
everything is optimized in the app
library is massive you'll find apps for
photo editing video editing productivity
everything is built-in and works
excellent the display is great it's not
reflective the battery life is great now
for the surface pro X the main selling
point is an ARM processor it's supposed
to give you good battery life and it's
both supposed to give you good
performance but because of the windows
and all the emulation and apps aren't
working properly the performance is poor
and the battery life is poor as well
because you have to run it
full performance all the time and not
only do you don't have a vast library of
apps like you do with iOS or Android but
most high-end good Windows apps that
people buy Windows laptops for also do
not work and for the future are there
gonna be more apps that are optimized we
really do not know which makes it quite
risky so yes it's a little bit less
expensive but overall the iPad works it
works now and it's not really going to
let you down so that is my opinion you
guys let me know your opinions down in
the comments section below I will be
putting out a full review once I test it
out even further if you guys want to see
that click that little circle above to
subscribe and you guys can see a couple
more videos right over there this man
maximized tech and I will see you in the
next video
[Music]